good evening everybody i'd like to thank
las for inviting me to speak to you
tonight about the complexities of
importing and exporting research fish
with the emphasis on europe
okay so this is the overview of what i'm
going to be talking to you about tonight
so obviously different countries have
different regulations
these different regulations can be
because
different countries are looking for
different things and what's important to
one country may not be important to
another
for example australia are very uh
very interested in protecting their
borders from
uh incoming
uh animals that are not native to the
country so they're very very hot on
those kind of things as an island nation
the uk is as well so i'll also be
looking at um exporting to the usa
and then as i've just mentioned
australia i'll also be looking at
exporting to australia
and then exporting to the eu countries
and then i'll be looking at uh in a
little bit more depth in importation
regulations
and the interpretation of those import
regulations to eu countries that are
specific to the uk and i'm going to take
a little bit of time to look at airline
and courier
regulations and then finally i'll be
looking at iata regulations
so as i said different countries
different regulations
but primarily most countries require the
following so that's customs invoices
shippers
certification most countries require
some kind of health certification
and within those countries in
institutions of them to vary with their
internal requirements for example in the
uk
i sometimes um
i will export things to different
institutions within the uk some of which
require health certification and others
don't um
legally speaking and i'm not going to be
talking about this um
at all the all laboratory fish are
covered by the asteroid which is the
animals and scientific procedures act
and
most places do not require a health
certification under that particular act
it's just an institutional
requirement
okay so these are just two examples of
what a customs invoice
might say so you're going to need to
give a date you may need to put it on
headed note paper
this one on our left hand side is our
ucl heading note paper sometimes you
don't require that you do need to
obviously say who the shipper is you
need to then say who who is going to
and what the contents are and this the
contents will vary
depending on who you're shipping to uh
and obviously what you are actually
shipping and then you have to say how
much value they have
when you're usually certainly at ucl and
usually when you are shipping uh
zebrafish embryos or zika fish
themselves for research purposes they
don't actually have um
they don't have a commercial value so we
always put some a very low value on them
and then these things are required for
people to you have to sign them
so that's custom invoices this is a
shipper's certification and have to
thank well korea at this point allow me
to show you this
and this is just basically telling you
uh so again it's very similar to a
customs invoice it tells you what your
what is being uh shipped
and you you know these are so this is
for the airline
um again very similar to customs
and this is a health certification so
these can come
like sometimes people are prepared to
have health certification
signed on headed note paper and they can
sometimes be signed by people like me so
i head up the facility i'm not a vet but
some places that this is the health
certification you require other places
do require that you have health
certification signed
by a vet
uh it again it all depends on a on the
institution and sometimes it depends on
the country you're shipping to
australia don't
require that a vet would
would would sign off on a health
certification
so if you're exporting to the usa you
need the following things a customs
invoice a shipper's certification a
health certification and again the
institute to where you are
to whom you are are shipping
will
their requirements will vary but so
these
the u.s
and canada as well so maybe this ship in
north america would just require these
things so these are amongst the most
simple exports that you can do
so so these are the three things that
i've already shown you the customs
invoice the shipper certification and a
health certification
i'd never shipped to anywhere in the usa
that had all canada that has required me
to have a vet signed health declaration
of any description so i always sign this
off myself
um so if you're exporting to australia
now you're talking about a country that
has very strict border controls so you
do need a shipper's declaration
and you also need an aqis import permit
which has to be
so it's the institute that you
ship to has to raise this so this is a
six-page permit which goes through
absolutely everything that you can
imagine
and it's
and it will ask you how you're shipping
what exactly you're shipping what you're
shipping in all kinds of things that's
you have a very detailed health
certification has which has to be signed
off by a vet
going over there
and within the import permit this
contains the detailed instructions
for the shipper the exporter of the
import regulations and instructions and
so and so it's not just to the
exponential she says also to the
importer
shipping to the to australia was once
one of the most complex
places you could ship to
okay and so this is what is required so
as i've told you
uh your
aqis
importation document is six pages long
you have to follow that very
very thoroughly you still have a
shipper's export
shipper certification
you have an additional health
certification
and you also have a customs invoice
okay so
now i want to talk about importing into
the eu
so this is under so uh i'm guessing that
everybody knows that
the eu
first came about because
uh
it was to help like trade between some
of the um
the european countries and since then
it's grown um in
it it's kind of outlook i suppose and
now we
we're constantly you know we're thinking
about you know how we
um make our regulations
don't all tie up together this doesn't
really work that well in some instances
and this is one of these instances
but this so this is the regulation that
you're supposed to follow to import um
aquatic things into
the into uh into the eu so it's
commission regulation eu number 346
stroke uh 2010
which it was an amendment of a 2008
regulation
so this is basically telling you how you
can import things into
the eu
okay and as uh so this comes from a
directive into
2006 which was the health animal health
requirements
for aquatic animals and products of them
so this is basically to protect
european borders from various diseases
that fish carry
so you might think that
some of some of the zebra fish stuff
that we do because none of those
diseases are actually applicable to um
zebrafish and certainly lots of
zebrafish fishing research which does
make it
somewhat strange but i'll come on to
that later
okay so this is another part of that
regulation so this is telling you that
you have to have certification and you
have to have requirements
for the market and the import into the
community look at agriculture animals
and
um
in the uk define agriculture so the uk
define research animals as part of that
as part of aquaculture
so again it's telling you yeah all these
things so
although that's the way that the uh uk
defined these things it's not it is this
interpretation varies from member state
to member state
so some countries will have a totally
different interpretation
of
of these regulations and some countries
in fact don't actually
define
um
don't actually define
laboratory fish as aquaculture so they
have
can quite often have lesser importation
um
requirements than somewhere like the uk
so someone like germany has
has has an interpretation of the of
these regulations which is
much closer to the uk than say the
belgium or french interpretation
of these uh
of these
regulations
okay so
in the uk so in 2010 this is actually
it's not 2008. we originally had decided
that what
cfas who are who are the governmental
body who determine what importation
regulations or fish come under
originally wanted health certification
using something called model animal
health certification for the import into
the european community of ornamental
aquatic animals intended for place
closed or ornamental facilities
now that was okay so but what that meant
was
that once we'd imported animals into the
uk we couldn't then
share them with any of our collaborators
in the uk
or
push them on to anywhere else because
closed means
that that they come into your facility
and that's where they stay and not only
those animals but the progeny of those
animals so
i think it's pretty fair to say that the
majority of people in the uk didn't
realize
that uh we would
that we were supposed to be importing
animals and then keeping them
in our own facilities so we were sharing
we were sharing different lines of fish
and then we got told by cfas that
actually we couldn't do that but because
uh
so this is what they did to help us so
they changed our certification from the
original one of closed ornamental
facilities
onto
aquatic animals for farming relaying put
and take fisheries and open ornamental
facilities which meant we could trade
we can trade our fish with other people
using
animals in research in research
however
so
this is what you need to do it so i this
is my uh this is the uh
authorization to um operate an aquatic
production business
in the uk which is what is the
legislation that we're working under uh
this is the one for this is an example
and it's r1 from ucl
so no one can bring anything into the uk
from outside
you can bring them in from you from
the eu but you can't bring them in from
anywhere outside the the uh european
union unless you have a
situation like that
so this is what i was telling you about
uh originally so this is the quite so
this is
uh the certification that has to be
filled in
by um
by the people that you're importing from
and this was the original one which was
the closed ornamental facilities
and this is the one that we have to fill
in nowadays and this is the one that
allows us to be if we if we bring in
things from outside of the eu this
allows us to share those um
to share those fish with other
facilities on other other scientific
institutions
okay
so i should point out that some people
have said to me because
because of the asper act which is uh
regulated by the home office
the asphalt says that nothing under five
days per virtualization is counted so a
lot of people get quite confused about
that and think that that's
a cfas regulation it's not a c-class
regulation
so fast say that you need certification
to bring in fish
or larval forms from third countries so
third countries just means countries
outside of the eu
um
so that's the only thing in fact even if
you're bringing us bone samples you will
still need the same certification to do
that
but because of these two different
pieces of legislation coming from two
different governmental bodies people do
quite often become confused
but it does you do need to have uh you
didn't need to have certification for
either fish or larval forms
okay so
why did we change from one to another
well i've already alluded to that really
uh
the idea of going on from closed
ornamental facilities to open ornamental
facilities was to make the import of
zebrafish
into the uk easier
uh
it's a bit debatable whether that is
really true or not there's lots of
people who say that it's not venturi
and that's because it requires fish to
be signed off
by an authority
in the country
by an official official governmental
body in the uk in the uh country of
export now in the usa that authority is
the usda it's not fisheries and wildlife
okay so
the problems with that with this
certification are
uh i don't think and a lot of other
people don't think that this is really
designed for um
fish that have to be used in uh research
of any kind
so you have there's a commodities
certification i'm going to come onto
that and show you what i mean by that
and it does require these approved
veterinary sign offs so
an approved governmental regular sign
off
so
in order in the us to be able to have
that
sign off you need to have
your facility
registered
or you need to have authority from the
usda to say that you are some kind of
agriculture
facility and they need to do an
inspection of it uh so it's quite a
complicated
procedure for the people who have to who
are you know who have
um
colleagues
in the uk to have to go through just so
that they can set so they can share
their fish with with their colleagues
and
collaborators in the uk and some
countries and this would be and so here
this is japan have just flatly
flatly refused
to do any governmental sign off of
research animals
i don't know this but i would speculate
that that's probably they do they will
do it with carp but i think that's
probably
because that's a commercial interest to
them and it's not to um
and research animals just aren't exactly
don't have that kind of commercial
interest
okay so this is a commodity
certification now if you look at this
you can see
let me just try something here
uh if you look here
you can see
that they're not pets they're not
necessarily for breeding they're
certainly not for quarantine
they're certainly not for circus or
exhibition
they're not usually for relay so
and um
this doesn't really make a lot of sense
and you can put other but then
and sometimes we've been told that what
we should do is write another box and
say therefore research
however this has a problem when they
come into the uk they say our
certification is wrong and they probably
threatened to prosecute me many times
over these
these certifications being incorrect
and this is the other thing that i was
telling you about
unless this is unless this is
signed off by uh
an official
uh vet
then this will also be this could mean
that you know i like that you know
they'll either
turn this around when it gets into the
uk or more than likely what they usually
do is let you prosecute people like me
um
so this does need to be signed off as i
say in the us
it's a usda varies from country to
country and this is the thing that the
japanese said that they won't sign off
or research animals so this has really
given us like quite a few problems
because
uh we do you know
the uk do have japanese and this is just
an example the uk
do have japanese um
collaborators so we've either had to
bring things in as constructs or so on
occasions we've had to bring them into
the
into
the eu through countries who don't
use this kind of legislation
to import research animals and then
we've had to import them from
other eu countries where it's easier
it's easier to actually obtain animals
from so it's
in some ways it's
just making life a little bit difficult
for scientists
like
the way i've got around um
around this this idea in uh
at ucl is that i've created two
quarantine areas
so
one quarantine area is where animals can
be transferred to other
uk
locations so this is one using the open
ornamental fish certification
and the other one i've not had to go
back to using the closed
um
close facility
certification so
i can only keep animals there and their
progeny can only stay at this location
so we can't ex we can't share these
animals with anybody else and this is
how
we're the only this i believe that we're
the only place in the uk that actually
employs this um
employs this way of importing animals
and the only reason that we did is
because i just had to keep talking to
cfas the governmental body would deal
with all this thing and say this is the
only way that we'll be able to import
some of our animals from some of our
collaborative collaborators in some
countries
but um okay the other thing to bear in
mind
is that airlines and couriers can have
regulations as well so
uh in the uk there are only two airlines
that will handle
animals used in experimental animals and
that's really because of uh like you
have
there are lots of uh
anti-vivisection
um
societies and movements and though
they're quite active in the uk although
they're not as active as they currently
are
on uh in continental europe
but they've
uh
they will
basically harass
airlines until airlines just you know
they they don't want the trouble of it
and then so they stopped taking on
experimental animals
uh there are only limited couriers that
you can use so fedex uh for example
so
we are limited on the curious that we
can use and sorry and i've already
talked about the limited airlines
prepared to accept research animals so
you need to think
uh if
about that uh if you are if you're
thinking of exporting into the uk
i would suggest that you use a
specialist career rather than just
putting things in boxes
so iota regulations
so
um you need to use one third of water
two thirds of oxygen or air
double bagged in polythene bags
um packed in a polystyrene installation
box and then outer cardboard box
they have it should be going with ir to
labels
live animals in this way up and you
should be able to go airport to airport
in 48 hours
so this is for adult animals and this is
just a little thing that shows you
uh
how to pack the animals as you can see
so this is your
polythene bag this is your inner
polystyrene box and this is your outer
cardboard box that's how you need to
transport
uh if you're using airlines this is how
you need to transport fish
this is adult fish i asked i have no
regulations whatsoever for embryonic
forms so that would be more
about how you uh
when you want to transport them i was
will usually transport in a culture
vessel
so
and again we follow this one level to
two-thirds air
that's what we do
so
my conclusions are that there are
different regulations
uh and they are country dependent and as
i said as i said at the beginning this
is going to really depend on
what the count the country of
import
what the country to which you're
exporting what they require and what
they're looking for as a as i said like
they they do differ in eu countries and
how they determine how they're going to
regulate things
some countries are
much easier to export to than others
but the iata regulations remain the same
no matter where you are
when you're importing and exporting to
okay i just like to acknowledge my uh
the ucl fish team
so because uh obviously i can't be here
doing this if they're not there doing
their jobs
any questions
right let's get a little look here
okay so
there are
no
questions so i would like to thank you
all
for listening and i will
hand back to roz thank you very much